sie haben natürlich auch schon gehört
dass jens spahn meinte wenn jetzt bei
allem was wir wissen man hätte friseure
nicht schließen müssen was haben sie
gedacht als sie das gehört haben
erst mal hallo nele ich habe gestern
ganz erschrocken reagiert also einfach
ich muss einfach sagen jetzt fast ein
zacken aus der krone gefallen nachdem
ich gelesen habe was hier sparen gesagt
hat also wenn ich jetzt mal ein resumee
für mich ziehen
fünf monate später nachdem shutdown im
märz april diesen jahres so eine aussage
zu treffen
es hat mich schon recht schockiert muss
ich mal sagen ich meine ich verstehe
natürlich die ganzen vorsichtsmaßnahmen
ergriffen wurden sind da bin ich völlig
dabei aber wir reden jetzt fünf monate
später darüber dass es vielleicht alles
sinnlos ist oder dass es einfach hätte
gar nicht sein müssen für die
friseurbranche für die ganzen
einzelhändler für die altersheime da
verstehe ich einfach die welt nehme also
ich frag mich dann immer bin ich hier
bei verstehen sie spaß
ja das ist aber nicht so also da
verstehe ich keinen spaß
natürlich werden gerade erwähnt wer
alles hart getroffen worden ist von
diesen maßnahmen wenn sie jetzt konkret
über sich sprechen
wie schlimm war dieser shutdown diese
fünf monate wirtschaftlich für sie im
grunde genommen muss ich jetzt sagen ich
bin immer ein mensch der in die zukunft
schaut und ich wusste wir werden das
schaffen ich habe ein ganz starkes team
die mich unterstützen im geschäft aber
nichtsdestotrotz in dieser zeit der
sechs wochen wo ich einfach gelähmt war
also gelähmt von meinem arbeitszimmer
von meiner ganzen situation her also es
geht ja auch man macht sich ja gedanken
man hat sorgen wie geht es weiter
dann wird auf einmal die ganze woche
selber ausgepackt dass man gelder
beantragen kann wo man auch noch
zögerlich reagiert weil man ja weiß das
muss man irgendwie alles zurückbezahlen
aber man möchte das geschäft absichern
man möchte die arbeitsplätze sichern
bei den arbeitsplätzen ich habe
mitarbeiter die haben kinder die haben
familie also ich hab einfach als
unternehmer eine große sorge gehabt in
den sechs wochen
und darum ist es für mich ein
unverständnis dass man nach fünf wochen
nach fünf monaten entschuldigung fünf
monaten sagen kann ach das war ja alles
nie so wir hätten es vielleicht gar
nicht machen müssen